I've had people come to me at work or
just in the community and say hey I saw
in LinkedIn that you were Google cloud
certified I want to find out more about
this and these are often career changers
or people who discovered to their
surprise that they really liked DevOps
or platform engineering or some some of
the background engineering and maybe
that wasn't the job that they were hired
for but they've realized that well you
know I have some technical skills and
abilities that I didn't know about and
in fact had a conversation with someone
who has a lot of information science
experience but is not a programmer she
would not consider herself a programmer
and she said can I pursue this I said
absolutely right you know there are
there are specialty professional grade
exams for applications developers but
you know this initial associate level
exam it's just a great overview of lots
of different things and I said if
nothing else what it will do is give you
a chance to learn a lot figure out what
parts you like and what parts you don't